Okay, back to the rendering
process of a single frame.
Once the browser knows which
rules apply to an element,
it can begin calculate layout.
Or it, in other words,
how much space elements take up and
where they are on the screen.
So, here's all the CSS
that we want to apply.
And layout turns this into
a collection of boxes like this.
In the tooling,
you'll see this as layout.
The web's layout model means that
one element can affect others.
So, for example, the width of body
typically affects the children's widths
and so on, all the way down the tree.
So the process can be quite involved for
the browser.
Sometimes, you may hear
layout called reflow.
It's the same thing.
The next step in the process is
to talk about vector to raster.
For example, the boxes we had before
were vectors like this, just shapes.
But now what we need to do is fill
in individual pixels, like this.
And that's what a rasterizer is for.
So, this is the layout we had before,
and
these are the draw calls that
the rasterizer will make to fill it in.
When done, it will look like this.
But that's a little too quick,
so let's step through and
see it build up the picture bit by bit.
So you can see, these rectangles
start to appear, then some text.
And we get a shadow, a white line,
a picture, and finally it tightens up.
The tooling is going to
show you this as paint.
You may have noticed in that previous
list that one of the calls was called
draw bitmap.
What we normally do is we
send things like JPEGs, or
PNGs or GIFs down the wire to our page.
But what the browser has to do is
decode these into memory, like this.
In the tooling,
you'll see it as image decode.
Potentially, we're doing something
like responsive web design.
And so the image may also need resizing.
Painting, as you may have noticed just
now, was done into a single surface.
However, sometimes browsers make
multiple surfaces called layers or
compositor layers and
it can paint into those individually.
So here I have a site and
this masthead has its own layer.
That means we can paint
the concept behind.
And we can paint the masthead itself.
The process of handling these
layers is shown in the tooling as
composite layers.
This masthead is a layer, but
because we have buttons for
next and previous on top of it they
are also turned into layers as well.
In this course, we're going to
talk about layer management
to make sure that you don't
create extra layers by accident.
Now, we can put all these
layers back together.
And so now we've finished painting
all the layers for our page.
To be honest, painting actually happens
into a grid of tiles like this.
I mentioned it for completeness, but
it's not something we get
to control as developers.
All of this happened on the CPU.
The layers themselves and
their tiles will be uploaded to the GPU.
Again, this will be included
in composite layers.
And lastly, the GPU will be instructed
to put the pictures up on the screen.
And that, in brief,
is how we get from a single request all
the way through to pixels on screen.